latest Bank to be seen to be struggling
that is First Republic a mid-sized Bank
catering for a niche market of customers
headquartered on the west coast of the
United States it's been troubled for a
few days concerned that it could
collapse and as a consequence and in
consultation with the U.S Department of
Treasury these 11 Banks including Bank
of America Citigroup JP Morgan Chase
Wells Fargo Goldman Sachs Morgan Stanley
the banking Giants they've clubbed
together to inject what's known as
uninsured deposits to the tune of 30
billion dollars into uh First Republic
in a statement a joint statement from
the the banks they say this action by
America's largest banks reflect their
confidence in First Republic and in
banks of all sizes and it demonstrates
their overall commitment to helping
Banks serve their customers and
communities Regional mid-size and small
banks are critical to the health and
functioning of our financial
system I think it's clearly designed to
be a demonstration of confidence it's
designed to help these smaller Banks
because there is a clear risk to to
individuals who bank with these Banks
and so they want to install install
confidence in them but it's also about
self-preservation it's another moment
where financial institutions and
governments are watching and monitoring
very closely